in honor of Batman's 75th anniversary my
he has aged well as a team we actually
have an all Gotham themed episode of DC
all-access and we're actually
celebrating all month long on DC Comics
comm yep and we're gonna be talking with
batman the animated series co-creator
bruised him all about his Batman's 75th
anniversary short and Scott Snyder he's
a pretty good writer he's actually gonna
give us an exclusive first look at the
upcoming Batman eternal weekly series I
guess like in a lot of ways we're just
throwing like a Batman birthday party
here at DC all-access it's true except
no clowns no clowns
[Music]
so last year we celebrated Superman 75th
this year is Batman 75th so how do you
go about creating a short that you think
was great for celebrating Batman it kind
of is a throwback to Batman's origins I
always kind of wanted to do Batman
as a actual period piece literally in
1939 the year the Batman first appeared
in the newsstand so it's kind of based
on the very earliest version of Batman
that Bob Kane did the character Hugo
Strange was right there he was actually
one of the very first super villains in
the Batman comics I wanted to
incorporate him and as far as what we're
seeing here it seems like they're a
little bit more in depth than most
storyboards that I've seen yeah did you
put a lot more work into these oh yeah
way more
yeah knowing that I was gonna do it in
black and white and that I was gonna
rely so much on the atmosphere and the
mood of it I came up with a storyline
where basically Batman gasses the
villains with these big clouds of tear
gas to kind of hide you know his his
movements while he's he's stalking them
and that's kind of tricky to pull off in
animation so I knew I had to be very
very detailed in the boards and in terms
of you know what I wanted it to look
like once we got the footage back we
went to town with digital effects to
kind of like just really really really
push all the fog almost every shot has
been treated digitally just to kind of
give it that that old-school kind of
look to it
[Music]
Batman eternal is about to launch the
thing you're most excited for fans to
see what is it well I think the thing
I'm most excited for fans to see in the
book is how much we have planned I mean
the appeal for me with the weekly series
was doing a book that moves so fast that
we could actually tell a ton of stories
from Catwoman to Batgirl and the mayor
to the Gotham Gazette just everyone we
want to go really big we want this to be
a series that week by week changes the
way Gotham looks feels is it will
greatly affect all of the books in the
bat world and it's the continuity that
I'm going to come back to from 0 year
Batman eternal is a weekly book which is
way too much work for just one man so
what is it like to be working with a
team but to be the captain of that team
well I don't know from the captain I'm
definitely I would say I'm sort of
though one of the two coaches or
something like that but I think the
reason that we work so well together is
that we have a similar sensibility about
making sure the story is very very
character-driven and really has big
emotional repercussions and status
repercussions for every character
involved so and on top of that each one
of those writers really bring something
exciting in my opinion to the book Rey
has huge interests in Supernatural and
the darker more twisted aspects of
Gotham and Tim is really into sort of
the more dramatic elements between the
personal relationships between
characters James on the other hand
really loves the supporting cast
I like the big bombastic moments so we
sort of complement each other in the way
that we're telling one big story but
each of us has a little neighborhood
that we kind of used to walk that story
through all right you guys check out
this full-scale Batman Arkham City
Batarang replica it is awesome and guess
what else we're giving it away to one of
you guys all you have to do is tweet us
what you think is one of the most
essential gadgets in Batman's Arsenal
don't worry you've got like 75 years of
gear to choose from when you tweet us
your pic though use the hashtag DC
all-access so we can find you
so Brian first thing you're stepping
into a book that's pretty important to a
lot of people you may have heard of it
nervous at all it's daunting but in a
good way and I think it brings out the
best in a greater yeah
what France tonight decide we were going
to sort of tell our own story and be a
little more self contained I mean there
are obviously a number of Batman books
he is like the most popular dude like
ever he's doing well right so yeah so
he's got a few books so we decided we
were going to take a step back and tell
more of a detective story that was more
about him and a murder case because we
can tell our story without having to be
as directly involved in the rest of the
gothic a degree right and so many things
that separate you also Francis's are
super distinct right I mean you work
with a guy who his imprint on things
people remember forever
are you writing better stuff because you
know he can basically build out a mini
veil as collaborators we you know we
come to story in a very unique way a lot
of times we just talk out the story and
he'll start drawing and we'll have
layouts of little title images of the
pages before one of us sits down to a
keyboard when you're writing with
somebody who is also so amazing
artistically I think it opens up
opportunities that it's a little harder
when you when you're writing and you
don't know who's gonna draw it or or the
communication is not as direct is there
anything that without spoiling anything
that you are really looking forward to
seeing this fans respond to we have some
new characters and and one of them is a
biker and you have really seen any biker
gangs in Gotham so I'll be really easy
to see what people think of these new
characters that we bring in so Ralph I
really appreciate you letting me in here
man thanks for coming but yeah for
insurance purposes I'm not usually
allowed in places like this that's
understandable but because I host the
show we do want to see your crazy 60s
Batman TV show collection great let's
take a look at it Blair
what sort of Batman collection would it
be if it's just out in the open as
anyone knows you got to go through the
bookcase yes oh yes there you go
this is amazing Wow
I'm assuming because it's the first
thing you really see when you walk in
the door
that one of the oldest pieces in your
collection is in this case yeah this
case is mostly Prime 1966 vintage
merchandise we've got the original
Batman and Robin action figures as the
first one's ever made we have all the
glasses we've got Batman Cola took me
years to find an empty bottle of Batman
Cola right one of my favorite pieces of
all of course these are actual
screen-worn gloves from Adam West's from
his Batman costume what I love about
this it says dear collector but you and
Adam actually have more of a personal
relationship Adam and I have been
friends for about 10 years now we talk
about your boyhood dreams come true to
be this obsessed with the guy in this
show and then have him be my pal now is
kind of can't put a price on that no you
can't what's this another one of my
favorite pieces of all time this is an
actual set used copy of the script from
the pilot episode that was the first
episode of course with Frank Gorshin as
the Riddler started all over so let's
take a look at what we have going on in
here
the button collection one by one I was
able to hunt those down that's all
original 14 buttons that you could get
in a bubblegum machine when you were a
kid everything you could think of they
made for Batman in the sixties I made
toothbrushes and plates and cups how
much are you still going out and
physically hunting and how much are you
just just eBay I do it all I get a
chance to travel around the country a
little bit for work so if you go into a
consignment store or a thrift shop
you're stunned sometimes what you run
across and the prices that you get there
versus what you pay online are
significantly better and you actually
have one like super rare thing
this is mr. Freeze's helmet one of the
helmets that George Sanders the first
mr. Frese of the series that he wore
from those two episodes and then you
have one more really really special
piece in here amongst we hardcore
sixties collectors this is the Holy
Grail
this is a mint-in-box ideal 1966 Batman
utility belt and it came with so many
pieces that could get lost broken or
disappear on you that to have it intact
mint in the box with the cellophane
still in the front it is one of those
pieces that every collector who loved 66
Batman is looking for well thank you so
much for your time my pleasure
appreciate it do you need to yeah it was
pretty good I did Pat you down
yeah fat van celebrating its 75th
anniversary all year long so make sure
that you subscribe to DC all-access so
you don't miss any of the fun and we are
celebrating two seasons of being around
only like seventy three more to go same
thing we're pretty cool either way
though we're going to commemorate this
momentous occasion by inviting you and a
friend to come to San Diego comic-con
with us all you need to do for a chance
to win a 4-day pass yep Hotel vouchers
airfare vouchers is click this link
below and answer a few simple trivia
questions really easy but guess what you
guys you're already winners you are
watching DC all-access thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you next time
[Music]